good afternoon everybody my name is Dave
Karger I am the chief correspondent at
Fandango thank you all so much for
joining us at this press conference for
disconnect a couple housekeeping things
as you all probably know this film opens
on April 12 and in the spirit of the
film if you guys wouldn't mind
disconnecting your phones except for the
ones that are up here because I guess
you need them for work I'm gonna kick it
off with a couple questions but I really
want to open it up to you all make sure
that you have time to ask the questions
that you all need from the cast and let
me introduce them real quick first of
all to my laughs max carrion Congrats on
this film I saw back in Toronto and I've
been actually thinking about a lot since
it's one of these movies that doesn't
leave your head which i think is the
best compliment you can pay it let me
begin by asking all of you your
characters have really interesting kind
of intense moments for each of you was
there one scene that during the filming
kind of kept you up at night while you
were thinking about whether it was going
to be frightening or a little bit too
scary to film it what was the one that
gave you shivers there couple of his
scenes that kept me up all night
III don't get a chance to cry that often
on film so I was sort of hoping that
talent would talent would come my way
that that day and I kind of cheated I
guess and just started looking at my
technology device my iPhone sort of
looking at pictures of my kids before I
started doing a scene where I had to cry
so that was a good little trick that I
did I found that's my answer how about
the rest of you
um we had a scene have you all seen the
film okay so their sign
my character is dealing with PTSD and
there's a scene that was very pivotal
their scene of the two of us in the car
outside of Schumacher Schumacher's house
were on they're clearly not connecting
up until this point but when they're on
this road trip something happens and I
think on Derek for the first time in
like almost a decade has he's doing
recon he's on a mission
you know he's finally doing something
inside of paper-pushing run anymore and
something beautiful happens in that
scene where Cindy sees that and there's
a moment where where Derek talks about
an incident back in in in Iraq where
he's hanging out with his buddies and
they're sitting in this vehicle and I
for some reason I think about that scene
because it's it's that moment cuz Cindy
just looks at him and she said he talked
about it and what I loved about the
scene the way it was written and and her
and I talked a lot about it was it
really had no point it's not a good
story it's not like it didn't happen
there was no punch line or was just this
moment in time where he was out there
with his voice doing absolutely nothing
and in that just hanging out being bored
he felt that camaraderie and for some
reason he said felt that in this moment
with Cindy sitting outside Schumacher
sounds like he talked about it and there
was this moment where they for the first
time actually see each other and when
Cindy's like you say something like
you've never talked about that or
something in it I don't know to me it's
II could come across an insignificant
scene but to me was one of the most
important one know when you were
preparing gosh I
be honest this film was so intense and
we were just just smashed together every
day and the hour of the day for 12 days
and it was so intense and I don't know
I'm always anxious everything keeps me
up at night but I think that it's
probably the end of the movie and I
don't want to give too much away but it
was understanding how yeah I guess
sometimes that's the fun of it is to be
that scared and to not know what you're
going to and how it will play but when
their character comes out and he has the
gun and how Cindy would deal with this I
was like I don't know it was really
actually like the last thing we shot I
say it was pretty intense and we do a
few times and that turned out I think I
think I worried about that scene a lot
it's always about wanting to tell the
truth in those moments anyway and that's
what Alec Henry Alex was so great at was
setting up an environment for you to
make sure that you were telling the
truth and sometimes when we have those
really impactful traumatic scenes
those are the ones that keep you up at
night before me because I you want it to
play and you want it to be real and you
want it to be honest and you don't want
it to seem forced and and so your
escapes death and it just hope it works
out but he was a wonderful because he
was never intrusive with the camera and
he always made sure that we were
comfortable with what we were going to
do and the camera stayed back and and we
never left until it felt right but it
worked and by the way I'd be remiss if I
didn't tell the audience here that henry
alex-rubin who you mentioned the
director of the film really wanted to be
here today he's back in New York about
to become a new father so that's why
he's not able to be with us but max what
about you what was the scene that that
you were most nervous
yeah I don't know if it was one scene in
specific but I remember starting out
like going into it I just wanted to to
achieve this comfort level and I think
that's the thing about Kyle is he's so
comfortable in his own skin and being
nude basically on set the whole time and
just trying to be as comfortable as
someone who does what gaming really is
you know so I think that was kind of
what I was constantly thinking about
just so it came off as authentic as
possible before I opened up to the
audience here I would imagine that the
excitement for you was to do something
that was 100 percent dramatic the crime
scenes and all did you feel like it was
a real fight for you to get this part
did did the filmmakers approach you and
that just made you happy or was this a
battle for you um I'm not sure how much
of a fight it was I can't imagine that I
was first choice you'd have to ask them
but I was just happy that it came to me
that there wasn't an audition process
but I just I'm really privileged that
they trusted me with it because it's
clearly something that is sort of uh
kind of threading a needle with stuff
like this and you need people who know
what they're doing and they didn't
really have a lot of reason to think
that that I could pull this off so I'm
just thankful that they that they
trusted me I'm lucky to be a part of it
it's a great great movie questions from
the ones question for max I loved how
you played this character I thought it
was so interesting that there are
moments when I mean there you are and
basically nothing with sex toys next to
you yet somehow he comes across as
really kind of childlike in certain
scenes can you talk about just striking
that balance when to make any more
sure went to make him more like a kid
yeah it was kind of like a constant
process that was going on throughout and
luckily had Henry there all along the
way and kind of met and talked to a few
people who are in this business and then
do this
and so it's kind of you know you want to
show when you watch web cameras they
always have this this the way that
they're able to speak to everybody and
how confident they are and how how
they're almost able to flip it on you
and make you feel like you're weird for
thinking that they're weird for what
they do so it's kind of a balance of
that and and obviously you know just
because of the dynamic of the
relationship it was important that Kyle
also seemed young because they kind of
really upped the stakes with he and Nina
and the ending I mean it made it all so
much more like what is the real reason
you know that she she can't be with him
you know yeah I mean I think I did more
research for this movie than any other
you know and then because one of those
things that when I read it it was so
exciting because I've never seen a role
like this especially for somebody my age
and so when the opportunity kinda came
it was like I wanted to do everything
that I possibly could to make it as real
as possible and for I'd like I had a
shame I remember going in and I was
doing something else and I'd like a lot
of facial hair at the time and it looks
kind of old yeah probably like I promise
I have a baby face underneath like this
constant kind of battle of like
convincing like I can do this you know
just give me a shot but
see the material and everybody else is
in the film I mean the thumb just comes
together isn't this this awesome
collaboration a lot of suspicious yeah I
mean the research was yeah I mean pretty
much a lot a lot of porn really because
everything you'd expect from watching
yet watching web camp sites and just
watching them interact with people you
know and and I mean different likes
different walks of life like young young
you know college kids moms who are you
know everybody's away and they're
decided webcam for a couple hours I mean
really interesting stuff but just trying
to take all that as a whole and
understand how they communicate with
their their audience in their crowd and
and how they keep them entertained and
get them into private do you guys have
any technology rules that you said it I
think I try to strike a balance because
sometimes when you have to respond to
something but oftentimes I really like
to hide it deep down in my purse because
I feel like big emails in Texas are like
they just ruin your day you're a bit I
was like having a great time and they
look at me you know I'm like that
element of surprise
I try to leave it out of my life it
gives me anxiety
and but I also I've been so scared by
all this like texting while driving and
God knows I've done it but now I pull
aside and I still think it's illegal if
your cars running angel a text on the
side of the road but I do that because
I'm I ever oh my god
you know saying can you get some milk
I just don't know myself so that's like
my new role for myself but in general I
I just like to live my life like and I
just find it sort of intrusive though we
all know like dreamin you gotta keep up
with things you gotta turn in emails but
there's a certain point in the day
around like 7:30 8:00 where I'm like I
don't look at again I'm definitely
turning it off same question I'm a very
lonely guy so it's just me I'll give you
my wife into my two daughters so I mean
I'm I'm not a big I don't really find a
problem with technology or television or
anything I'm a product of it I grew up
watching TV I don't think I'm too dumb
or too crazy I think a big
responsibility falls on the parents just
sort of well the kids can't watch the
wire but there's great educational stuff
than watch TV if it is TV time or you
know there's great apps on the iPad that
you know are interactive and educational
and so I I'm not that parent my wife a
little bit more so you know we try to
sort of good-cop bad-cop it but I don't
really don't really see a problem with
it you know
my mom always just somebody's your photo
of the table so I just I try to stick to
that one as much as possible but
obviously I've been given this industry
it's like here I feel like you're always
so attached to your phone because it's
you have emails and people calling you
and it's like if you're not there well
then you're in trouble yeah why didn't
you answer the phone we need it you know
we have something important to talk
about so but yeah I mean if I'm not
dinner with somebody than I try and at
least stick to the basics of leaving the
phone away and you know have a
conversation with a person I'm with some
people could vote all their phones in a
pile on the table at the beginning of a
dinner and the person who reaches in for
their phone has to pay for the dare Hey
how much do you all disconnect from
what's written about you on the web you
know before it was you know you could
just not by People magazine you could
just not buy the Enquirer now you're at
home you're checking email what did you
get a Google Alert with your name how
much do you look at that no I think
that's the way of print like I I don't
want to know I mean you know I think
it's I'm not very active on social media
that's an understatement
I'm not I don't not even know I'm not on
Facebook or Twitter or Instagram or
anything like that and it's son I'm not
I think it's wonderful that they're out
there and they're fantastic and you know
I have a lot of siblings and friends
that use it and it's great for them but
on you're absolutely right it's such a
connected world and when I'm on a plane
people know where I'm going before I
even know where I'm going kind of thing
it's like you land where like you know
people know where you have lunch
yesterday or who you had lunch with and
it's a way of keeping something
something private in your life for me at
least is to kind of try to avoid sharing
everything with everyone and it also
it's kind of like what you said I think
it's about on to like
no pun intended but this connect you to
it to actually turn off your phone when
you go to your country house or
someone's if you get won't go on
vacation a few days I turn off my phone
I check it once it akai turn it on if
it's an important message I'll call back
otherwise that can wait and you know I
wouldn't be worried about like if you
know with agents and managers they'll
learn to accept it you like I'm gone for
a couple of days if it's important leave
a message I'll call you back if not I'll
be back next Tuesday and for me it's
really important to have that because it
is are aiming life is crazy in here so
you traveled you busy there's so much
going on and it's it's important to have
those moments so we can breathing we can
actually just be present with the person
the person or the people here there you
read nineteen comments out Paul is so
amazing and then xx one man hands right
what are you like you know yes but I I
do believe though that you know what you
got to keep up with the times I'm into
social media I'm trying to find my
comfort with it because I feel like if
you don't keep up with the kinds then
you get left behind and you just need to
you know you just this is what's
happening so and I find them as an actor
I think it's really challenging because
what I love about films is being able to
be completely transported when I watch
an audience member I don't really want
to know all those details about
because it ruins the movie from me you
know sometimes why I love foreign films
more than any because I really really
get to escape and so now there's a new
thing I'm like what do you share and
then is it still enjoyable for people to
watch her films when they're going she
doesn't like that she'd never do that I
mean she hates bad whatever it is it's
um I'm finding my way I'm not real
comfortable with it yet
but I'm trying to go okay how can I find
some peace with it post something never
look back like send it to somebody else
like say this never look back at it so I
can like you know be part of this age
because I don't know and I wasn't Alex I
was like damn it somebody convinced me
to do this like I do it but I'm just I'm
finding my way with it and I'm just
trying to hopefully find some kind of
balance so that it doesn't get in the
way of people enjoying your film self
and so you can always be different
people no it's like I don't want this
sound negative or like we're so like oh
Internet is horrible it's amazing like I
have friends that are very active and
they're saving the world there's like
Kristin Bauer a dear friend of mine went
to Africa to save elephants and she got
all her fans involved and it's
absolutely wonderful so you can use it
in a way that's actually really great it
doesn't have to be about like how
amazing your or come watch my show or
come like look what I'm wearing today it
doesn't have to be narcissistic that's
what I'm saying it also to me the film
is not about it's not a didactic film
about how horrible the internet is or
like how evil the internet is or how it
ruined our lives our storyline had
nothing to do with the Internet the
problems that Cindy and Derek are going
through are not related I mean it's not
Internet related it's a guy with PTSD
they lost a kid they can't really he
doesn't want to talk about it that's the
issue the internet for them is just an
escape because it's complicated and it
hurts and it's messy to actually sit
down with with your wife or your husband
and talk about real issues it's a lot
easier to just
your computer and you know play poker so
that's what it is it's an escape but
it's not and like it doesn't have to it
that's not the cause of the problem no
you and you're actually right because
with our storyline she would go to a
support group and she can meet a guy a
support group and cross those lines it's
just the film is really about human
relationships and in this new age and
it's a brand new world that we're living
in that we didn't like I don't know
maybe max but the rest of us probably
didn't grow up with it and and the
relationships don't change it's just the
scene changes a little bit how do you
guys get your characters in that mind
space to kind of crank between those two
changing a mind space from a moment I
don't know I think what our job is his
actors is just try to be as accurate and
as mindful as possible of what the
audience is going through and receiving
and processing and just try to pivot in
time with them and if it's a situation
where the character should look a little
out of control or do something a little
bit stupid and it's your your job to to
act into that in a believable way I
guess if I'm understanding your question
correctly yeah I think this would be
just as as president the scene that
you're a mystical continue with that
just to be as present in the scene that
you're you know that you're in just a so
that it becomes like a natural thing I
mean if that's what the scene is then
you're just doing it yeah I saw for
Derek on the internet theft almost as a
blessing in disguise
I think up until that point he has no
control he is
it's he's conflicted because he's a
warrior is a hero and he was that and
now he's a paper-pushing run and he
there's so much guilt there and so much
pride he doesn't want to talk to anyone
about he can't do that on so I think the
moment of like you talking about taking
control is when this horrible thing
happens they get all their money not
that they have a lot but the money they
have stolen and he's back I think that's
the moment where he's like taking
control again he's suddenly a marine
again he's on a mission he's gonna do
some serious reconnaissance here he's
gonna track this guy down and suddenly
he's got a mission and I think that is
there's a spark there something happens
that Cindy can see in his eyes that for
the first time he's actually alive in a
long time maybe stronger and for us it
brought us closer made us fall in love
again and realized that material things
were of little importance but the love
and the relationship was more valuable
than anything so go ahead and steal
people's eyes that you enjoy about every
day I I really like that I mean I can
connect with so many more people
throughout the day than I ever could
with just a telephone in fact I can be
on a telephone call and be emailing or
texting somebody else as well so you
know is I don't know I would imagine
everyone appreciates that efficiency of
communication again I see it as a huge
positive and any of the obvious
negatives are just another thing to
navigate as a as a person is just this
generations challenge
one of them but there'll be another one
for the next generation and our parents
had had a different one before us so I
think the net is a huge positive yeah in
a way of with that I think that's the
script is extremely well written and
very intelligent and so relevant on so
many levels but I think the personal
Baretta it felt very personal to me
because of my own experience from from
being in the Navy in Sweden and also
when I did a show called Generation Kill
miniseries a couple years ago that takes
place in Iraq it's you follow a platoon
of Recon Marines the first five weeks of
the invasion and we shot that in Africa
it took about seven months in I got to
know a lot of the Recon Marines when I
was out there and when I read this it
just felt like Brad Coleman was the name
of my character in nine generation
killer a guy of real marinas when I read
is this felt like Derrick could have
been
Brad's best friend it could have been
one of those guys he probably was one of
those guys that was out there on and who
came homemade who didn't get the the
treatment the help that he deserved and
needed and there is a lot of pride these
are proud men and they're warriors and
they come home and they felt like I
survived three wars
come on like I'm not gonna go to shrink
and talk about my issues it's a problem
because they're not they're not getting
that help but some of them in Derrick's
case he's not opening up either he
doesn't talk about it so that's why I
felt very personal in a way that because
I know
a lot of guys that are I mean the thing
is I was I was in on in a unit that it's
part of the the Swedish Navy but it's
it's more kind of yeah I'm not gonna go
into details but it's quite it's part of
the Navy in Sweden I did not hang with a
lot of PTSD you know we're not fighting
16 Wars like it's it was a very intense
experience but it's 200 years was the
last time we were at war so I can't I
don't carry that burden that load that
that that Derek is hearing around you
know we've talked about some of the
positives and negatives of the internet
but if you have any online habits you'd
like to share that or just you know
could just be counted as entertaining
diversions or hobbies for you or
educational you go to chapter II site we
learn quite a bit words with friends I
understand you I already heard fresh it
I love astrology zone yeah my son likes
math monkey that's a good one
so going back to what you suggested
about all the positives of the net do
you think we'll ever repel as a society
against social media to think that I
know there's a lot of great things like
that but do you think that in some sense
for the everyday Joe I don't think so I
just don't think you can keep the genie
in the bottle I you know I mean people
want to communicate were we're you know
that's what our species does and this is
just a more efficient way to do it and
you know you can you can motivate a
bunch of people to stand up against
oppression you know and free a whole
country with it I mean it's like this is
fantastic
so if some people are going to abuse
freedoms I mean we see it with gun
control sometimes then it's gonna it's
gonna put it on the front page of papers
and some people are gonna say put it
away but I you know it's the whole thing
about one bad apple you know we
shouldn't ruin it all so people are
gonna abuse freedoms but that's part of
its fabric and it falls on us as parents
or whomever to help people through those
instincts and and try to keep it
positive for the director was saying
that he kind of challenged
you guys in that scene in the car to
make each other laugh with silly porn
titles I was curious if you remembered
any of the ones you came up with that
weren't used in the hotel room first
firms with them I we both the night
before that scene in our talents like
googling like Google eyeball porn that
was not excused - what do that yeah of
course madam watch them all diligent
actors we weren't having fun but we was
a very enjoyable experience and it's
night when you don't know anybody you
don't know anybody you think don't know
someone and you just suddenly thrust
together it's exciting and scary you
don't know if it's going to work and
they're already going through normal
health one another but somehow I mean to
me the first day at lunch when you
knocked on my door and I was at sex with
you know having sex with me it was that
when you knocked on my door at lunch if
you came in with you Paula found this
amazing Jamaican restaurant around the
corner from where we were shooting up in
Yonkers and you came with a beautiful
late plate of food and I was like Paula
yeah every day
lastly rejecting me and movie bag but
also I think when you choose something
that's set you know there are moments I
want this it's not all heavy but there
are definitely some intense moments you
need to kind of laugh in between tale
that's a way to survive right yes so we
did have fun like eating Jamaican food
together or like going to and from set
or between setups and stuff it's on
otherwise you completely consumed to me
that's very important I mean I think
it's my job to let her know what what
the functionality of a lot of this stuff
is and what the ramifications could be
if she sends that text or that email or
that picture it can be disseminated you
know without any of her control
whatsoever so that would be something to
look out for and then after that if she
makes a mistake she's gonna obviously
learn a painful lesson I mean it's a
it's the hot stove Theory you know you
can tell them do you're blue in the face
it's hot and then sometimes the best
lesson is if they actually make the
mistake and so I mean I just don't think
I'm gonna be the kind of parent that
sweats you know putting my kid in a
bubble and and I never wanted to let
them out you just you try to prepare
them for all the obstacles and hope to
make the right decisions and and
bullying is not something exclusive to
the Internet I mean it that's been
around forever so your lunch whatever
now it's just such a different way so
that's the heart it isn't a didn't lead
to people killing themselves right
that's the tough part I think because
this is the world where and I do think
well as Alex said I don't think there
was any sort of didactic effort here
this isn't some sort of public service
announcement i think that hollywood's
always looking for new baskets from
which to write screenplays whether they
be dramatic or comedic and i think
technology is certainly not new but
there are some some nice interesting
warts in it that that make for good
stories this is this is one of those but
you know at the end of the day it's
about human interaction which is what
any movie is about this is just a device
a tool through which we connect some
stories and presents the challenges to
these people so I don't think there's
some huge lesson to learn or at least
not attempting to be taught but I think
everybody should see if you like a good
movie I mean I think it's I think it's a
great movie it's it's certainly a lot
better than a lot of the films that I've
done it certainly is a lot more dramatic
than the stuff that I've done and so I
appreciate that I appreciate the way it
looks I think it was beautifully shot
and
and scored and it's just a great film
can i sorry can I just add that it's it
was so I saw it for the first time up at
Santa Barbara Film Festival a couple of
months ago and it was it's always
horrible for me the first time I watched
something I'm in because you kind of
dissect your own performance you know
like that was way too big too much but
we met five and ten million ten minutes
before we came in here for the first
time like I've never met this these
ruggedly handsome men for in Andrea
Riseborough is a dear friend of mine I
was wrapped before she you guys in the
start of your storyline so it was so
wonderful for the first time to watch a
movie that I'm in to be able to watch
their stories in as a member of the
audience
I wasn't like watching it as like oh man
I remember that thing that was horrible
why did I do that why did I could
actually sit back and really enjoy it
and I thought that those two storylines
were amazing and the fact that Henry is
the first-time filmmaker is great
narrative filmmaking crazy like the way
he pulled it off of those like just I
thought it was phenomenal and I think
people should go see it because Jason is
a funny guy but this is super serious
and he's amazing take out all the other
stuff it's just fun to watch and it's
exciting and it's it's a ride and then
if you can lead with what I met whatever
message you want and I think Henry Alex
it was such a perfect trace directive
because like a documentarian like a
great documentarian you're not meant to
make a judgement you're meant to present
it and I think that that what was so
beautiful about the film he doesn't make
any statement you were left to be an
intelligent audience member and see see
it how do you choose
you choose to make your own judgment
it's up to you there's no hammer on your
head
so you know for me movies first and
foremost are going to be entertaining
and meant to take you away and this
movie does but the great ones actually
make you think afterwards and hopefully
change a little bit covered it on
everything every aspect I mean I guess
specifically for for my generation one
thing that's really interesting is that
it's even all these storylines there's
kind of something that you can you can
relate to and and it just kind of makes
you reflect and and think about how
connected I know I am and my generation
other generations are but and how much
we we use technology and use the
Internet and how it really does play
such a huge part of our lives whether it
be good or bad but other than that I
mean I think they covered all the
reasons why you should see the movie
thank you thanks everybody
thank you thank you